في انتظار اعلان النتائج الرسميه اردوغان
يتجه للفوز بالرئاسه
وانصار اردوغان يبداون في الاحتفال
واردوغان يبدو واثقا بالانتصار
[موسيقى]
روسيا تحذر الغربه من تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتله اف 16
هذه الاخبار وغيرها لكم من قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في انتظار اعلان النتائج
الرسميه للانتخابات التركيه في جوله
الاعاده تشير الارقام الى تقدم الرئيس
التركي المنتهيه ولايته رجب طيب اردوغان
للفوزي بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه على حساب
منافسه من المعارضه كمالك الجدار اوغلو
اذا وهي مرحله من حبس الانفاس اذا دخلت
فيها تركيا في انتظار اذا حسم هذه النتائج
وخروج لجنه الانتخابات هيئه الانتخابات
بمؤتمر صحفي لاعلان النتائج النهائيه رئيس
هيئه الانتخابات التركيه احمد ينار كان
قال ان نتائج الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه سوف تكون متاحه في
وقت اقصر من نتائج الجوله الاولى نظرا لان
الانتخابات بين مرشحين اثنين فقط
هذه نظره على النتائج الاوليه اذا لفرزيها
الاصوات التي اشرت الى تقدم اردوغان باكثر
من 55 بالمئه مقابل 44% لك وذلك بعد فرز
55% من الاصوات اردوغان بدا واثقا من
الفوز قائلا انه لاول مره في تاريخ
الديمقراطيه التركيه تجرى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه على جولتين متمنيا تكرار النسبه
في الجوله الثانيه ومشددا على انه ضامن
الفوز من الجوله الاولى اما غريمه
فدعى الناخبين الى التصويت من اجل التخلص
من نظام استبدادي على حد وصفه بعد الادلاء
بصوته في مركز اقتراح في العاصمه انقره
قائلا لانصاره ان الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
وحريه البلاد ستنتصر اخيرا
من تركيا الى روسيا حيث حذرت موسكو من ان
الغرب يلعب بالنار بشان تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات من طراز اف 16 وزير الخارجيه
الروسي اعتبر ان ذلك تصعيد غير مقبول
قائلا ان الولايات المتحده بدات تفهم
باقرار رئيس اركانها بصعوبه استعاده
اوكرانيا جميع اراضيها ايضا عن امله في
ابتعاد الاشخاص العقلاء عن الدعم المتهور
لنظام النازيين الذي صنعه الغرب بنفسه في
كييف بحسب تعبيره
في خطوه انتظرها الصينيون كثيرا اقلعت اول
طائره ركاب محليه الصنع من طراز سي 919 من
مطار شنغهاي الى بيكين في رحلتها التجاريه
الاولى وعلى متنها 130 راكبا الصين تريد
لهذه الطائره ان تكون منافسه لايرباص اي
737 ماكس بعدما اجرت الطائره اولا رحله
تجريبيه لها في عام 2017 بعد سنوات من
التاجيل وخضعت لعديد من الرحلات التجريبيه
منذ ذلك الوقت ورغم انها صينيه الصنع الا
انها تعتمد على بعض المكونات وقطع الغيار
الغربيه
ونختم بهذا الخبر الغريب حيث شهد التل
ابيب في اسرائيل حادثه طريفه تسبب فيها
صرصور في استنفار امني بعدما اثار الفوضى
والذعر بين رواد مقهى بشارع ديزنجوف وبحسب
ما ذكره موقع ووالا الاسرائيلي فان سبب
الفوضى والصراخ هو رؤيه هذا الصرصور تحت
الطاولات ما اثار فزع سيده اسقطت منضضتها
ارضا يعتقد رواد المقهى ان هناك مشكله
امنيه الامر الذي تطلب استدعاء الشرطه
التي وصلت لتلقي او لتلقي القبض على
المتهم فوجدته مجرد صرصور
[موسيقى]